we are faced with something absolutely
incredible and it is the uninvent of one
of the greatest concepts ever devised
which is not to say that America ever
functioned according to its objective we
moved toward it we fought one terrible
war over a race already we may be headed
toward a second but what is not well
understood by I think almost anyone who
is doing this is one what happens when
you take a flawed but highly functional
society like ours and you break it right
there is a sense and you will hear
people say again and again that we're
gonna have to destroy this thing in
order to build something better and what
they don't understand is what a power
vacuum does mm-hmm if they had gardened
if they had tilled up some soil and they
had decided that that was the key to
wiping the slate clean and planting
their crops they would discover that
they had just liberated all sorts of
weeds that they weren't counting on and
that it's going to take an incredible
amount of work to fend them off so we
have a worse problem and I would I would
analogize at the following way I want
you to think about nuclear reactors and
in particular I want you to think about
Chernobyl now a nuclear reactor is not
in and of itself a complex system it's a
complicated system but a nuclear reactor
does not run itself it is embedded in a
complex system of humans the designers
who set the thing in motion the people
who run it the people who regulate it
and you could walk into the control room
of a nuclear reactor and there are a lot
of buttons you could flip that would not
have a catastrophic effect but you don't
know which ones are which and the
Chernobyl story actually tells us
something important for those of you who
don't remember and I would actually
recommend you check out the HBO
miniseries on what happened to Chernobyl
what happened at Chernobyl was a safety
test it was a test designed to make us
more secure and they were going to run
through some systems checks and it
happened that some of those systems
checks set things in motion that caused
the reactor to quickly overheat and
people's tendency to delude themselves
about what they were seeing prevented
them from
shutting it down in reversing course
quickly enough and the rest is history
and the point is what we are seeing in
America today is the flipping of
switches in something even more complex
than a nuclear reactor and the proposals
for switches to flip next are quite
frightening now I don't know what to
make of the story of the McCloskey is
this couple that came out in front of
their home with guns and were filmed and
photographed as a as a protest movement
moved through their private street it's
a complex story and you will see it
portrayed in diametrically opposed waves
depending upon which source you go to
either it was white people brandishing
weapons at peaceful protesters because
they were you know looking at the
boogeyman in front of them or it was
people who were flagrantly frightening
them by marching across private property
and threatening to invade their homes
it's very difficult to figure out
exactly what happened what what appears
to be going on now is that having come
to public consciousness this couple is
now a flashpoint for a war that some
people seem to want to start and if I'm
to understand the story correctly the
protesters who were the ones to trigger
this by marching through the McCluskey's
Street are apparently going to come back
and that is not in and of itself so
surprising but what I understand is that
they have asked the police for help so
that presumably they don't need to
brandish weapons of their own they the
homeowners say the homeowners have asked
the police for help and apparently the
police say they can't help them they
have apparently also contacted they the
homeowner they the homeowners have also
contacted private security and nobody
will take the job I think that's
actually not surprising but here's it's
not the job of security of private
security firms to take any job that
comes to them well it certainly
shouldn't come down to it every single
American has the right to have their
their rights protected by the police and
you know as
sam harris points out in not his most
recent podcast but I think the one right
before the one in which he addresses the
statistics surrounding police violence
and race he says that the monopoly on
violence is one of the greatest
inventions that humans have ever come up
with and I have to agree with him on
this so that is a reference to I believe
it's Max Weber --zz suggestion that
government is a monopoly on violence
that is its inherent nature which does
not mean that government is inherently
violent what it means is that a
carefully wielded threat of violence if
you do not abide by the rules is what
keeps people in line and if the rules
are very good then the threat to punish
those who step outside of them
ultimately if you step outside of the
rules somebody with a weapon comes and
they take you away and you go to a court
and you face due process in this country
the possibility of violence implicit or
explicit is what in fact keeps the peace
right and you know if you have let's say
flagrantly violated the rules in some
very serious way let's say that you have
assaulted somebody without cause then
somebody with a weapon they collect you
you face due process and you out you end
up in a prison now that prison is a kind
of violence right those bars that keep
you in are effectively engaged in
violence you can throw yourself at them
in order to engage in your freedom to go
somewhere and it doesn't let you it's
the equivalent of violence but in any
case the point is I find something very
chilling about the McCloskey story I
have no idea who these people are what
they're about but what I do know is that
you and I face something like this and I
do know us okay what we faced was you
and I you and I hurt for those who can't
see that you just gestured to me you're
talking not to the entire audience now
but right we face something very much
like this you and I at Evergreen face
something like this where a mob that was
possessed of crazy ideas about what we
were about began to engage in flagrant
violations of the rules and threats of
violence which ultimately became real
violence and our boss the president of
the college happened also to be the boss
of the police because the police were a
campus police force they were real
police not a security force they were a
police force but
he was in a position to tell them stay
out of this which meant that the
protection that we normally have from
the police was pulled out and we were
left on our own with a mob that was
clearly hell-bent on reeducate
and as I've said before I don't think
they know what they would have done if
they had caught up to us and we had
refused to go along with their
description of the world which we would
have so a very dangerous situation
the police refusing to be involved this
is something most people have never
faced and the fact that we are now
seeing that little experiment and
anarchy that happened at Evergreen being
brought into the wider world where
people who have run afoul of this
protest movement who can be portrayed as
zealots are going to be left without
police protection this is the flipping
of one of the switches in the reactor on
which we are all depending you flip the
switch that says I mean what is supposed
to happen if the police refuse to help
you and no security force will come to
your aid when you try to hire them what
recourse do you have right one would
think that the recourse would involve
going to a court and saying I have the
right to police protection the police
are not protecting me and you must
insist that they do it by some sort of
court order but we know also that
because this revolution is happening in
a horizontal fashion that the courts are
not immune to it so in some sense that's
which is read for a reason we know that
pulling the police out and making it so
that people cannot get a redress of
grievances in a court is the thing that
will cause this nation to come toppling
down right you cannot have some
populations who have access to a court
and other populations who don't now that
is not to say that access to courts has
been even in our history it has never
gotten to even but if you want to remove
it from some populations and you want to
inscribe that into the core modality
that we have with each other there is no
way that this experiment can persist
right it is not an evolutionarily stable
strategy which means we're headed to a
power vacuum yeah and this this moment
is not
as it would have us believe about
redress of grievances it is about rather
the thing that you and I have both been
saying from the beginning about flipping
the tables turning the tables of
oppression correctly identifying that
there has not been equal access to
things like courts and justice from
police in our nation's history does not
validate the conclusion that we shall
change who has unequal access going
forward and that that will make things
right
it does not yep and I would say that if
one is going to evaluate whether or not
the protests move it in the street is
about redress of grievances then you
need to think about things I don't know
if the McCluskey's are are descended
from pilgrims but that doesn't sound
like a pilgrim name so the question is
in some sense if these people are having
their right to to be protected by the
police eliminated on the basis that they
somehow are descended or they are as
guilty of slavery as those who held
slave themselves slaves themselves or
something then there's a question about
well are we gonna sort out whose guilt
goes to what depth that's preposterous
it can't happen and so you know is the
solutions are simply incoherent
[Music]